spot at Martian button was at the
misconduct Hearing in South West London
and Martin the misconduct hearing
couldn't take place of course until he
had been in court but he was still
receiving his salary until very very
recently wasn't he
yes he was paid up until December when
he admitted the first and the majority
of those charges and he'd been suspended
for over a year but um as we keep
hearing from the new commissioner the
disciplinary process is often very
elongated and complicated anyway in the
last few minutes he's been sacked by the
Metropolitan Police it was a hearing
that lasted nearly two hours and you
might ask what took them so long but
again a complicated process that has to
be done in a very formal manner in the
chair making these decisions was the
assistant commissioner Louisa Rolfe and
she had two things to consider really
the question of whether his behavior
amounted to gross misconduct tick and
whether that gross misconduct merited a
a final warning or the sack and quite
clearly to any reasonable thinking
person you know there was only ever one
decision so he has now been formally
sacked from his job assistant
commissioner Rolfe said that it was a
sickening and horrific case and she
hoped that she would never see it's like
again Carrick wasn't there I mean he's
clearly in prison awaiting uh his
sentence but he was told that this was
happening he didn't make any uh
representation he didn't have any lawyer
to look after his interests and although
there was somebody from the police Rank
and file police Federation he wasn't
there in any capacity to represent
carrick's interest he was purely there
as an observer so Carrick knew this was
happening and he didn't offer any kind
of mitigation there was a lot said
principally from a lawyer for the
Metropolitan Police who described his
crimes as heinous targeted and
deliberate he also said that carrick's
crimes had had a catastrophic effect on
his victims and his victims families he
also went on to say that policing has
taken a step backwards as a result of
this case all of that was listened to by
the assistant commissioner who at about
quarter past 11 ruled that a his conduct
was gross misconduct and he should be
fired so again as part of the formal
process he'll be told about that and
Carrick will see him in court in another
three weeks time when he's going to to
hear what his sentence will be and he's
clearly looking at a life in prison